bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono fa dj ed oggi siamo su
un persone ragazzi dopo a fermare non
potevo veramente non potevo crederci che
avessero fatto anche ampere sonic è una
cosa splendida
siccome ragazzi so già che ci saranno
due miliardi di trappole porto piano
privati lo sapevo conoscendo a fermare i
ragazzi la piattaforma dopo è una
trappola quindi non ci va comincia sono
rimasti feriti quando si dice che ha un
pixel di sabah al culo questa è da
momento epico sicuro l'unico pezzo di
stronzo ragazzi lo sapeva tanto sta cosa
prima o poi non sapevo io lo so io lo so
io non sono un cazzo ragazzi io ed evo
ix
siamo all'inizio abbiamo sono morti
cinque volte all'inizio sugo scusate vi
era lo sfogo momentaneo non ce la
possiamo fare ragazzi ce la posso fare
mica soffrendo tutto regalando non ci
riuscirò mai più dicitura ok ok ok una
sega denuncia non ce la posso farlo
perché io sono un deficiente ragazzi
devo cercare diciamo di essere un po per
gente perché c'è per la mentalità un
click cosa cazzo se come ho fatto
arrivare fin qui non lo so neanche io
ragazzi non importa lo so fermi ok va
bene così non solo a morte un traguardo
allucinante quindi va bene così
4 c'è un'altra favino ci vado perfetto
perché cazzo sono tornati indietro
madonna la coordinazione madonna che
però madonna che pro di madonna la
coordinazione guarda lo guardano ma
[ __ ] saperlo sappe minchia lo
sapevo ragazzi un mimava guardando
avanti csis
no ragazzi prenderà la fine quella tana
di quella [ __ ] uso libero muta tipo
di merce
[Musica]
ragazzi non so come non chiedetemi come
cazzo fatto non lo so livello 2 livello
si passò 25 morti e un miracolo ve lo
dico miracolo ragazzi non ci posso
credere perche come non detto vediamo di
farti niente non ce la farò mai niente
niente
sono morto sono morto già cinque volte
nell'arco di neanche quattro secondi
fantastico e la cosa allora fatemi
riuscire ad andare avanti di qui si si
[Musica]
non so ufficialmente cosa cazzo ho fatto
ma va bene così deprimente devo salta
oggi ho già trovato un passaggio segreto
per no non lo troverò ma ci sono
riuscito la prima volta e non ci
riuscirò mai più c'era un caso segreto
tipo qui si usi un cazzo però affanculo
il cocco il cocco perfetta io qua sopra
non so se saltarci o no perché ho paura
di prendermelo aka pranzi cosa molto
probabile ma devo farlo perché non so
dove andare
j blidge uno che sto sudando non ci
posso credere
la sopra sopra l'effetto madonna
santissima ci siamo e va già bene poi è
soprattutto si è una cosa più grande ma
guarda lo riguardano come sia stretgia
guardalo
[Musica]
ragazzi voglio condividere con voi
questa mia immensa gioia per essere
riuscito a finire questo livello con una
botta di culo che probabilmente non avrò
mai più ma chi se ne frega andiamo
avanti l'importante è che ce l'ho fatta
perché ci sono dei pesci mi sono già
incassati non avevano se la vecchia
parti studi audio sono già in qualche
belliche allora vediamo di saltare sto
pezzo prima di sì si guardi madonna
madonna che testa di minchia scavo
ragazzi sono abituato tipo adam fermare
of work at niente niente niente continua
a saltare sopra il beige ed un rullo si
ok no no ok ok mamma mia mamma mia che
fenomeno guardalo lì qualcosa sto
facendo ragazzi non lo so neanche a
probabilmente mehmet metà di quelle
erano piene di spine ma non importa
non devo correre riuscire a saltare sto
punto non è difficile difficile non è
difficile
no non vedi che sono già una
coordinazione uguale a quella di un
lombrico all e madonna madonna
ok ok ok ok ok cielo saperlo so già vice
come io mio santo ma praticamente
ragazzi fa incazzare che alla fine ci
arrivi abbastanza velocemente però ha un
po
e tua sorella tricheco dicevo ragazzi ci
si arriva abbastanza velocemente però a
un passo dalla fine qualcosa che lo
mette nel deretano per forza perché cioè
non devi non devi vincere in poche
parole credo di sì ole ole dopo dopo 74
cribbio di morti ce l'ho fatta perfetto
enfants fermer ball
adesso sa cos'è sto casino oddio ragazzi
serie b è vabbè ma la lava non vale
cazzo ma per capire perché si è riempito
di lava c'è già non bastava la merda di
prima pure la lava ci dovranno mettere
fantastico media che genio che genio di
sta minkia è una cosa allora capo
software e con che buco di culo mi salvo
certe volte perché non lo so se è
normale cioè sono più fuori che dentro
ma non importa dove scene a capire dal
minimo ok ok tuca tuca un cazzo ragazzi
se riesco a finire sarà mentre oggi vi
giuro che corro nudo per casa una roba
pazzesca e devo questo non lo prendo
questo non lo prendo non riuscirà allora
terminati montato non lo so che mi
prendete per il culo quindi non lo
prendo ok ok madonna che però madonna
che pro questo non lo prendo invece
dovevo prenderlo porca [ __ ] alla rai
andrà avanti senza morire perfetto
perfetto dove sono molto prima potrei di
morirci e potrei incazzarmi di più è una
via d'uscita
no ok fino a saltare direttamente chi
cazzo
musica emergente cazzo di chiara gadoni
non riuscirò mai più
se riusciamo a completare sto cazzo di
livello senza riniziare per forza beh lo
sapete quanto lo so se ok allora vediamo
riuscire sì sì tanto non ce la farò mai
più a tornare a quel punto di vino non
ce la farò fottutamente devi morire è la
centesima ragazzo vogliamo aprire prima
di alla prima di arrivare a 100 le
calciava devo fare ce la devo fare si ok
ok ok ok ragazzi non solo la morte prima
prima di superare le 100 incredibile sta
cosa se riesco devono farmi una statua
da qualche parte ma non credo che ce la
farò mai ma ci provo
ok ok si può morire mondo morire ok
adesso il dilemma resta se devo salire
su sto cazzo di cosa possa devo saltare
sul cerchio credo sul cerchio cerchio
che all assalto di merda che se rimbalzo
con il mio culo faccio di più devo
finire stop schifo di gioco perché chi
viene a diarrea cronica se ce l'ho fatta
ragazzi è stato è stato pazzesco non lo
farò mai più alto due ragazzi anche
ancora e abbassando intuitivo c'è chi
fosse cose quale salto perfetto questo
non ha pericolo nemmeno questo nemmeno
questo nemmeno questo qui da fetta resto
se questa musica mi mette un non lo so
un'ansia pazzesca perché essi ma io li
dimentico che sono un deficiente ragazzi
ma è certo devo riuscire ad perché no
perché veramente sta musica sono
ascoltate e inquietante cioè non lo so
mi mettete è una cosa strana non lo so
perfetta la finca ci siamo come cazzo
saltare o a caso ci ha mandato qui
perfetto non era il punto giusto che
cazzo devo fare qui che ne so io qui sì
sì ok ok non miracolo mira allora
[Musica]
è una cosa allora qui si cazzo ragazzi
non mi chiedete come cazzo fatto non lo
so presumo che devo andare qui sotto
perfetto magari se centro il punto la
prossima volta è meglio di questo
livello perché mi chiami stava uscendo i
nervi dal dal dal fianco non lo so
perché altro che andare in palestra mi
che ha trovato al tapis roulants
perfetto cazzo nonché ragazzi allora
dove rimane non mi ricordo allora devo
saltare tipo qui si rimane ragazzi
rimane l'ultima cosa che ovviamente io
dovrò saltare direttamente sull'anello
per che cosa mi ammazza sicuro ma ormai
le soste cose perché cazzo è normale
cioè si vada anche casey ma ci mancava
solo quello guarda infatti sei stronzo
la fisica di sto gioco ragazzi la fisica
è pazzesco e una cosa che non ho mai
altro che newton si sta rivoltando nella
tomba come povero cristo era cavallo da
fatemi capire che cosa devo fare qui ok
ok mi che impossibile chi ha detto
guarda lì
guardalo league madonna madonna madonna
si è adesso come cazzo rifare sì sì sì
ok ragazzi si madonna madonna e lì su
credito stadi
si no
guardalo si si no dove sono morto come
sono adesso tu mi devi dire come cazzo
sono morto non mi ha toccato niente non
ho toccato niente
oddio riga poi nel sonno ragazzi poi la
zon dopo anni è l'ultimo questo dovrebbe
essere l'ultimo livello fantastico lo
faccio tutto di fila senza neanche
guardare e nun ce la farò mai neanche a
partire effettivamente si ragazzi voglio
provare a farlo senza una vita a sorsi
come se fosse possibile
ok bel primo l'ho passato abbastanza
bratti sì sì un cazzo si vabbè che cazzo
ci hanno messo credo allora proviamo
vedere su perfetto per guardano come se
le stragi come si destreggia il
proiettile di merda il proietti era
arrivata avantissimo in una vita sola
non è possibile che faccia fare sta
parte nostra noi che come sto facendo
lega non mi chiedete non lo so che
caccia che spara sti cosi che già è il
casinò senza non si ok chi è che sta
sparando porca [ __ ] chi ora vediamo di
riuscire a fare un qualcosa di sì vabbè
ma prima spari sopra un pò di sotto del
cdt cazzo ok ok perfetto o che adesso è
sparato alto vini ok e [ __ ]
dottore ma lo sapevo che eri tu ne ho
preferito
[Musica]
va bè ragazzi 204 morti fantastico sono
veramente contento con questo dovrei
aver dimostrato che tutti gli han fell
compreso mario e sonic non li temo e ci
sono riuscito ad entrambi è veramente
una soddisfazione personale guiu ve lo
dico non ci dormo la notte per la
soddisfazione di chi ha fatto che sono
uscito di testa non chi avesse dubbi
concluso più l'episodio quindi ragazzi
spero che il video vi sia piaciuto
ovviamente i ragazzi debito è piaciuto
questo strumento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e come la divido
frazione descrizione cioè essere tristi
discrete lì ci becchiamo non fosse unito
e lo ragazzi